i grew up in a small town in the midwest
my older brother had a number of
neurological difficulties and to watch
how
he was treated i just from a very young
age understood that there were people in
this world who are born into
circumstances that make life much more
difficult for them i also continued to
be sort of shocked that there were
things that i was told i couldn't or
shouldn't do because i was a girl and i
think that sort of set the tone for me
to really
understand deeply from an early age that
there are people who are disadvantaged
through no fault of their own
i started in
1978 and i think at that time maybe 20
22 of the class were women it was still
unusual for me coming from such a you
know baseline of understanding about
business about power about how the world
worked i had never understood that and
the subtext of the business school was i
began to understand it was in the air
and that was enormously valuable for me
for whatever
i might want to do in my life
project redwood is an organization open
to nagsb alums we were interested in
working together with other gsb alums on
the issue of global poverty
and it came into being because we're all
at our 25th reunion which is kind of a
big thing and it was awesome and there
are probably 150 people in the room and
you're just sort of sitting there bathed
in the sense of there is great work that
can be done that these individuals have
stepped forward and done i kept looking
around like somebody's going to stand up
and say
we got to do something here together as
a class nobody did so i finally did you
know i'm still the girl in the
front row and i said we're 25 years out
for my career we have extraordinary
access to financial resources to power
to contacts what if
what if we as a class
decided that we would
band together and create some kind of an
entity that would work to make the world
a better place and that was the spark
that created project redwood
we look for the best projects where
dollars are leveraged to help whomever
lift themselves out of poverty what i've
been involved with
is called hero women rising it's in the
democratic republic of congo
and it was founded by an extraordinary
woman
many years ago
who created a school where women
regardless of what education level they
have coming in can learn a trade these
are women who then can go out and begin
to earn money on their own
we support farming communities we've
provided support to about 60
organizations around the world
so far to date because we are mbas we do
analyze this and it's pretty clear that
we've helped almost a million people
across the globe lift themselves out of
poverty at this point
the student body at the gsb is now
highly attuned to
entrepreneurship in the social space and
doing work to help make the world a
better place i mean it's really just
part of the air they breathe now a
number of those current students have
joined us and boy do we need and want
them and besides they're going to be the
leaders of patrick redwood in 30 years
and we need them to start now
i think most of the entrepreneurs that
we
fund and the organizations that they
create i think those will endure but i
also think there's always a new
generation coming up behind it it seems
to be a kind of basic human instinct
aside from all the ones that we know
about that aren't so admirable there's
also one about that human impulse that
so many people have to make things
better not so much for themselves but
for the people that they see around them
that's going to endure that's going to
endure
i'm carol head co-chair of project
redwood
you